كنا نتحدث بالأمس عن كيف أن
الأنفلونزا العادية الآن أكثر فتكًا
في الوقت الذي يستغرقه منذ
أن بدأ هذا الفيروس في نشر الأنفلونزا العادية بشكل
أكثر فتكًا ، لكنك تشير إلى
أن هناك على الأقل لقاحًا
فعالًا إلى حد ما مع اللقاح المنتظم.  الأنفلونزا
مع هذا ليس صحيحًا بعد ، ليس
لدينا لقاح ، هناك لقاح
يعملون عليه في الواقع ، لقد أمضينا بعض
الوقت في المعاهد الوطنية للصحة نتحدث إلى الطبيب
د.  Fauci الذي يدير هذا
التقسيم المعين حول ذلك ودعونا نستمع إلى
ما قاله على وجه التحديد حول
أن ما نفعله هنا هو
أننا نطور لقاحًا سنضعه على
الأقل خلال ما نسميه المرحلة الأولى
وهي "  سنقوم باختباره لمعرفة ما إذا
كان آمنًا وإذا كان يحفز نوع
الاستجابة التي تأمل أن تكون
وقائية ، فقد لا نتجاوز
المرحلة الأولى وما يقوله
أساسًا أن ليندا هي مرحلة تريد منا
تحديد ما إذا كان هناك شيء آمن بشكل طبيعي
انتقل إلى المرحلتين 2 و 3 في بعض
الأحيان لا تملك هذه الرفاهية ، لذا إذا كان هذا
الشيء آمنًا ويبدو أنه يظهر أي نوع
من الفعالية ، فقد يطلقون
لقاحًا كهذا مبكرًا لمحاولة
التخفيف من انتشار هذا ، دعني
أريكم فقط  هناك شيء آخر إذا كان بإمكاني أن
يعطيك فكرة عن كيف
ينظر مسؤولو الصحة العامة حقًا إلى هذا المربع
، فهناك نقطتان مهمتان ،
إحداهما مدى قابلية انتقال هذا المرض ومدى
خطورة المرض وإذا كان
لدينا هذا الرسم البياني ولكن  من الناحية النظرية ،
سيكون الصندوق موجودًا إذا لم يتم إرسال شيء ما
بشكل جيد وكان منخفضًا جدًا
من حيث الخطورة في أفضل سيناريو حيث
قد تتخيل أسوأ سيناريو هو المربع D
عندما يبدأ شيء ما فجأة في الانتشار
بسهولة شديدة ويكون أيضًا شديد الخطورة
أنت
، ابن عم فيروس كورونا الصيني الجديد
لفيروس السارس ، وضع
المجتمع الدولي في حالة تأهب منذ
بدء تفشي المرض في الصين في
ديسمبر ، يستمر ارتفاع عدد المصابين
والمرضى الذين لقوا حتفهم ،
لذا إليك ما تحتاج لمعرفته
حول فيروس كورونا كورونا  الفيروسات عبارة عن
مجموعة كبيرة من الفيروسات الشائعة بين العديد
من أنواع الحيوانات بما في ذلك البشر في
حالات نادرة ، ينتقل الفيروس فعليًا
من الحيوانات إلى البشر وحتى
أكثر ندرة من شخص لآخر وهو
ما يعتقد العلماء أنه حدث في
هذه الحالة الآن بشكل نموذجي  في أعراض فيروس كرونو
تشمل سيلان الأنف والسعال والتهاب
الحلق وربما صداع الحمى التي
يمكن أن تستمر لعدة أيام لأولئك الذين يعانون
من ضعف في جهاز المناعة.
فرصة أن يتسبب الفيروس في حدوث
أمراض الجهاز التنفسي الأكثر خطورة مثل الالتهاب الرئوي
أو التهاب الشعب الهوائية ، لم يكن هناك سوى نوعين
آخرين من فيروسات كورونا
المعروف أنهما مميتان متلازمة الشرق الأوسط
التنفسية المعروفة باسم فيروس MERS
الذي تسبب في مشاكل تنفسية حادة
و  قدرت مراكز مكافحة الأمراض والوقاية منها (CDC) أن ثلاثة
من كل أربعة من كل عشرة مرضى مصابين بفيروس
كورونا قد مات واحدًا آخر هو
متلازمة الجهاز التنفسي الحادة الوخيمة أو السارس الآن
التي يبلغ متوسط معدل الوفيات فيها حوالي 10 ٪
مع كبار السن هم أكثر ال
يروسات عرضة للانتشار من ال
شر.  يعتقد علماء الحيوانات أن
فيروس كورونا بدأ على سبيل المثال في
الإبل ويشتبهون في أن السارس بدأ مع
قطط الزباد ، أما بالنسبة لانتقال العدوى من إنسان إلى آخر ،
فغالبًا ما يحدث ذلك عندما يكون
شخص ما على بعد ثلاثة أقدام من
الشخص المصاب ومع هذا الفيروس الجديد
الذي لا نعرفه بعد.  عندما يصبح شخص ما معديًا تمامًا ،
ومدى مرضه عندما يفعل ذلك اعتمادًا
على مدى إصابة الفيروس بالسعال
العطس ، المصافحة يمكن أن تسبب
التعرض ، لا يوجد لقاح للحماية
من هذه العائلة من الفيروسات ، لا
يوجد علاج محدد لفيروس كورونا
معظم الوقت ستختفي الأعراض من
تلقاء نفسها
، وينصح أولئك الذين يصابون بالفيروس بالقيام بما يلي  الأساسيات: شرب
الكثير من السوائل والنوم
كما يمكن تخفيف الأعراض بقدر الإمكان عن
طريق تناول أدوية الألم أو الحمى ،
ولكن إذا ساءت الأمور ، فمن
المستحسن مراجعة الطبيب ، يمكنك
تقليل خطر الإصابة بالعدوى عن طريق تجنب
الأشخاص المرضى وتجنب لمسك.
العيون والأنف
والفم وبالطبع اغسل يديك
بالماء والصابون بقدر المستطاع لمدة
20 ثانية على الأقل
لقد استيقظت وأنا أشعر باليأس الشديد يا حزين
غاضب معظم هذا بسبب
نقص المعلومات ومعرفة ما يجري.
لقد تمكنت من
الاتصال بأسرتك والدتك على
وجه الخصوص ، هل هي قلقة ولكن
أمي تقلق عليّ أنا
أحبها ، تبلغ من العمر 88 عامًا ، أخبرتها أختي
بذلك  كل الأشياء التي أفعلها هنا
ولا أريدها أن تقلق بعد
الآن وأود أن أراها أداما إذا كان
بإمكانك الخروج ، فهل ستغادر ،
نعم أنا ممزق وبصراحة
سأخبرك الآن  لا أستطيع المغادرة ،
لن أغادر لأنني إذا كنت ناقلًا ،
فلن أكون غاضبًا أو أي شخص آخر ،
وهذا مجرد خطأ في جانب
الحذر أو يكون أكثر برودة ، لكنني
وصلت إلى حد اليأس المطلق
لم يتواصل أحد معنا كمغتربين في
هذا المجتمع ، يتعلق الأمر بكشف
الحقيقة والحصول على الحقيقة
هنا ، وأعتقد أن الحكومة المحلية
أفسدت الأمر ، لذا سنضع الأمر على هذا
النحو وأعتقد أن
الحكومة الأعلى على الأرجح  لم أكن أعرف
وأعتقد الآن أنه يتم التحكم في الضرر ،
هذه ليست مزحة ، هذا ليس فيلمًا ،
هذه ليست لعبة ، هذه ليست لعبة فيديو ،
إنها حقيقة واقعة وعلينا أن
نبدأ في التعامل معها بجدية أكبر